hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american superhero drama and fantasy
movie called the new mutants
danielle moonstar who is usually called
danny wakes up from her sleep after the
chaos around her house caused by the
tornado
soon her father takes her away from the
house and runs into the forest to hide
but before that she still manages to
grab something that is in her drawer
there her father hides her in a tree as
he runs back to the village to help the
others
a few moments later she can only fall
silent when she stares at her father
dying in front of her eyes
feeling scared she continues to run
deeper into the forest causing her to
fall and eventually falls unconscious
later she feels confused when she wakes
up in an oddly empty hospital with her
hands cuffed she tries to search for
help but suddenly dr cecilia reyes comes
to her room it turns out that she is the
one who runs the empty hospital
she then comforts dany so she can open
the handcuffs on her hands
danny also tells the incident that
happened to her last night because of
this dr reyes gives her back the
necklace that she brought before she
left the house with her father last
night it means a lot to her because the
necklace is the only present from her
father that she has until now
meanwhile their conversation is
monitored by the cctv in the room
dr reyes also informs danny that
actually she is not an ordinary human
being but rather has unique mutant dna
thus she advises her to remain in this
hospital until she learns the effects of
her power and how to control them
the next morning dr reyes gathers with
four other teenagers who have unique
mutant dna like danny there are samuel
guthrie aka cannonball eliana rasputin
aka magic roberto dacosta aka sunspot
and ronnie sinclair aka wolfsbane dr
reyes has brought each of them to the
hospital because each of them has
experienced or inadvertently caused a
horrible tragedy starting from sam who
accidentally collapsed an entire coal
mine where his father and co-workers
work killing them all completely roberto
unintentionally burned his girlfriend to
death using his superpower ronnie
escaped her devout catholic village by
killing the priest after he branded her
as a witch because of her superpower and
eliana was enslaved and sexually abused
as a child by a creature called the
smiling man
all of them also possess unique
superhuman abilities due to mutations in
their dna
roberto can manipulate solar energy sam
can fly at jet speed eleanor has
interdimensional sorcery powers and
ronnie's lycanthropy allows her to turn
into a wolf
after a while dany approaches them and
she is introduced as the new teenager in
the hospital
afterwards drive reyes asks ileana to
take dany around
as she walks out dany tries to escape
from the place but strangely ileana does
not care about her at the same time a
wolf follows her from behind
unfortunately she instead hit a force
field surrounding the entire hospital
grounds causing her nose to bleed it
turns out that dr reyes herself is also
a powerful mutant who can manipulate
plasma energy force fields preventing
the five of them from leaving the
facility
iliana then laughs at danny to make her
angry because of it danny wants to hit
her but lyanna immediately uses her
superpower to dodge
[Music]
furthermore she comes back to the
building and desperately plans suicide
from the church clock tower while the
wolf is watching her from below at the
right time ronnie comes and prevents her
from committing suicide bringing their
relationship closer
still around the hospital grounds they
meet with sam who is practicing his
superpower
at night sam and robert are chatting in
the laundry room while being watched by
dr reyes from the control room
in the meantime danny is dreaming of the
incident when her father was killed
making her psionic energy elevated back
in the laundry room sam is startled by
one of the washing machines making a
strange sound
feeling curious he checks the washing
machine as it takes him back to his past
where the miners and his father are seen
when he wants to go back a miner
suddenly attempts to hit him using a
pickaxe sending him flying violently
from the washing machine
the next morning danny takes a bath with
ronnie where she notices a mysterious
w-like mark on ronnie's shoulder without
any explanation ronnie leaves her alone
in the bathroom
in the therapy room the five of them
practice controlling their superpower
guided by dr reyes afterwards ileana
abruptly antagonizes danny in the dining
room causing them to fight therefore she
wants to slash danny with her sword but
at the right time dr reyes manages to
shield danny using her superpower then
they are both punished by being locked
up in an isolation room
there eliana recalls her past about the
smiley man while danny hallucinates
seeing her past and a black shadow from
the sky that looks like a demon bear
consequently dr reyes comes to the room
and decides to take danny's blood sample
for further study
the next day the mutants want to play
truth game using the lie detector in the
attic but secretly dr reyes is also
watching them via cctv
as the result they are reprimanded by
her the next day later eliana manages to
make dr reyes falls asleep using drugs
seizing the opportunity they party and
have fun freely that night collectively
the five teenagers believe they are
being trained to join the x-men under
strict supervision
after that roberto approaches aliana who
is swimming after he kisses her he feels
heat on his body because he remembers
his past when he accidentally killed his
girlfriend his girlfriend's charred form
suddenly appears from behind him causing
the alarm to sound which wakes dr reyes
they all come to the swimming pool and
find roberto's body is already on fire
dr reyes immediately pushes him into the
pool so he can return to normal roberta
then becomes angry and wants to run away
from the place after he finds out that
eliana was deliberately bothering him
but according to the cctv footage he was
in the swimming pool alone while iliana
was in her isolation room
however dr reyes realizes what eliana
has done earlier and decides to lock her
up again in the isolation room soon
ronnie begins to have horrifying real
visions of her past tragedies
suddenly she is getting branded on the
shoulder by the same priest whom she had
previously killed causing her to turn
into a wolf
after that iliana deduces that the
visions are the result of dany's powers
manifesting themselves the ability to
physically manifest fears illusions or
other thoughts from a person's mind
feeling upset she immediately strangles
dany and takes her to the limbo but
luckily dr reyes is able to inject a
sedative into ileana
the following day danny comes to
ileana's room to return her hand puppet
of a purple dragon called lockheed turns
out the hand puppet fell off while she
was being soothed last night she also
says that limbo is a realm created by
her and lockheed back then
in the control room dr reyes receives
danny's examination results from her
employers which is the essex corporation
she is ordered to collect danny's dna
and then euthanize her because she is
considered the strongest and
uncontrollable mutant that can harm them
as reyes straps her down on a gurney
danny's panic causes her powers to go
haywire in another room eliana and sam
are attacked by physical manifestations
of ileana's childhood abusers the
smiling men
meanwhile danny's voice calling for help
is heard by ronnie making her suspicious
and immediately looking for her
fortunately danny still can use her
powers to discover dr reyes's true
intentions before ronnie arrives in half
wolf form and mauls dr reyes forcing her
to flee from the room
at the same time sam meets with roberto
who is trying to break through the
hospital's outer barrier which has now
contracted in diameter
all of them regroup in dr reyes's office
and realized that dr reyes was training
them to be assassins for essex in order
to escape they must kill her to deprive
the force fields of their power source
using ronnie's sense of smell they
managed to confront dr reyes who warns
them that dany is too powerful and will
destroy them all
she then restricts them all with force
fields when she tries to kill danny
again by asphyxiating her with a force
field the demon bear which is danny's
own greatest fears manifested through
her power suddenly appears and devours
dr reyes making danny renders
unconscious eliana then uses her
superpowers to travel to limbo where she
retrieves a glowing sword armor and a
tiny physical manifestation of lockheed
to battle demon bear while ronnie tries
to reach through to danny's subconscious
and urges her to wake up
eventually sam and roberto also join the
fight as well as ronnie but all to no
avail in the meantime danny is visited
by her father's spirit who encourages
her to face her greatest fear because of
it she awakens and confronts the demon
bear calming it down and thus
dissipating it in the end the group
finds out that the force field
surrounding the entire facility has
disappeared they decide to leave the
place and look for the nearest town
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching